[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition du journal sur
tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 6 janvier
voici les titres
elle est née officiellement au 1er
janvier l'université paris saclay
regroupera à terme 65 mille étudiants et
10 mille enseignants chercheurs au sein
de cet établissement lu vs qu est pour
le moment membres associés explications
à suivre toute cette semaine retour sur
les événements qui ont fait 2010 9 dans
les yvelines ce soir première
rétrospective de janvier à mars dernier
avec au menu grand débat national
communes nouvelles et catastrophe
écologique
enfin du sport et du football le
département n'a plus de représentant en
coupe de france le fc versailles dernier
rescapé a été éliminé samedi par les
normands de granville en 32e de finale
avant de développer ses titres toute la
rédaction de tv 60,18 s'associent à moi
pour vous souhaiter une très bonne très
belles années 2020 on l'espère pleine de
réussite pleine de bonheur et de santé
c'est le plus important
[Musique]
les ville d'elancourt et de maurepas se
sont rassemblés ce matin pour signer le
contrat de construction et de gestion du
futur centre aqualudique
après deux ans de réflexion le centre
sera finalement construit sur le terrain
de l'ancienne piscine de maurepas un
équipement avec 5 à bassin en inox qui
se veut moderne et adapté à
l'environnement les précisions de
mathilde et demi ils encourent et
maurepas bénéficieront d'un taux de ce
nouveau centre aqualudique le contrat de
délégation de service public vient
d'être signé un soulagement pour le
maire de maurepas qui attend ce projet
depuis cinq ans on arrive au bout d'un
long projet qui avait démarré depuis
2015 on a perdu du temps à cause de
conflits politiques inutiles 1 2 ans il
aurait pu vite livré beaucoup plus tôt
et voilà aujourd'hui la finalité est là
on propose aux élans courtois comores
patients un équipement ludique un centre
aqualudique composé de plusieurs espaces
santé et bien-être qui sera accessible
pour les habitants des deux communes un
projet qui se veut ambitieux et qui veut
moderniser les équipements sportifs de
la ville
aujourd'hui le résultat est là ça va
être aussi certainement un modèle aussi
d'expérimentation parce que beaucoup de
deux villes dans en france ont ce
problème il ya une obsolescence
aujourd'hui du patrimoine notamment en
ce qui concerne l'équipement des
piscines caste alias est le nom de ce
centre aqualudique un projet
intercommunal qui s'adapte à
l'environnement le chantier va durer 21
mois
ah donc avec une livraison prévue en
avril 2022
on a à peu près 140 mille heures de
travail sur ce chantier en effectif de
pointe ou à la raison va être à peu près
une petite centaine à peu près 90
personnes on a prévu ou elle a un
effectif de points donc ça va faire du
monde sur ce site effectivement
mais voilà pour un bel ouvrage à la fin
les gros travaux commenceront dans six
mois coût de cette réalisation un peu
plus de 24 millions d'euros
et en ce début d'année plusieurs
changements on en parle avec vous aurez
lironde bonsoir de la rédaction de tv 78
notamment un nouvel établissement
d'enseignement supérieur c'est
l'université paris saclay oui alors elle
a été créée par décret le 5 novembre
2019 mais c'est bien le 1er janvier 2020
qu'elle est entrée en vigueur
alors elle est composée de sept
établissements dont 3 université
paris-sud du vs tueur l'université
d'evry et de quatre grandes écoles
centrale supélec école normale
supérieure de paris saclay l'institut
d'optique et agroparistech de grands
organismes de recherche sont également
associés à cette nouvelle entité
notamment le cnrs l'inserm ont encore et
l'ina quelle est l'ambition de cette
nouvelle université du coup quelle place
pour lui ubs qu alors l'ambition de
paris saclay bien c'est de devenir la
première université française figurent
également dans le top 20 mondial des
meilleures universités d ornans rappelle
donc cet établissement d'enseignement
supérieur s'étend sur plusieurs
départements l'essonne
les yvelines les hauts-de-seine une
partie du val de marne alors de son côté
l'université de versailles saint quentin
50 ans a dévoilé aujourd'hui comme vous
pouvez le voir sa nouvelle identité
visuelle pour le vécu qui est membre
fondateur et bien et c'est une véritable
opportunité de faire partie de cette
entité comme nous l'expliquent son
président alain puisse lui vs küssel
même si elle est très performante comme
le montre son classement récurrent dans
le classement de shanghai où elle figure
dans le top 500 et parmi les 20
meilleures universités françaises ou
même dans certaines disciplines parmi
les deux meilleures mondiales en
sciences de l'atmosphère par exemple
c'est que pour elle vient apporter tout
son potentiel à ce nouveau consortium
est aussi profiter d'une marque nouvelle
université paris saclay qui va lui
permettre de se développer
et comment cela va se mettre en place il
va falloir quand même un petit peu de
temps comme vous allez le voir avec ce
calendrier
fin janvier la prochaine échéance fin
janvier début février va se dérouler
l'élection des conseils de l'université
paris saclay jusqu'en 2025 lu vs cul
pour prendre donc l'exemple de l'ubs est
ce qu elle va participer à la
gouvernance et s'étale
horizon 2025 que la fusion aura lieu
entre lu vs qu à l'université paris
saclay pour ne former qu'une seule
véritable entité un chiffre pour
terminer 80000 c'est le nombre
d'étudiants qui devrait faire partie en
2025 de l'université paris saclay un
chiffre qui est amenée à augmenter au
fil des années merci aurélie pour ces
précisions dans l'actualité aussi
l'ouverture demain du cles2 las vegas le
consumer electronics show se déroule
jusqu'à vendredi c'est le plus grand
rendez vous de l'innovation au monde et
chaque année comme chaque année des
startups françaises vont participer à ce
rendez-vous lamberth renora bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le sillon et le
co-fondateur de jirau lift vous avez
participé à l'édition 2018 et 2019 du cs
et grâce notamment pour la première
édition de votre participation à votre
victoire lors du challenge paris saclay
organisé par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvelines déjà pourquoi
pour une startup même si vous niez pas
cette année pourquoi c'est intéressant
et important d'être au cs de las vegas
en fait c c'est important parce que
c'est le lieu où il faut être
il faut être présent il c'est là qu'il
ya tous les concurrents les autres
entreprises
c'est là qu'il faut se montrer c'est
aussi donc c'est donc une très belle
visibilité et c'est des belles de très
belles retombées après des retombées
presse et est retombé aussi en termes de
de visibilité pour le staffing par
exemple des personnes nous contacter
nous disent ah bah j'ai vu que vous
étiez allé au cs tenez votre jeu vous
donne mon cv est ce qu'il y aurait pas
un poste pour moi j'aimerais faire
partie de l'aventuré etc mais on aura
l'occasion de parler des retombées
spécifiquement pour giraud lift est ce
qu'avant de participer la première
participation c'est en 2018 est ce que
c'était comme un rêve pour vous d'y
aller à ce csc tu es dans un coin de
votre tête en nouvelle tout à fait tout
à fait c'était
vraiment une très très belle opportunité
de pouvoir y aller en 2018 la note pour
la première fois on n'y pensait pas
vraiment à ce moment là on pensait c'est
toujours un peu pas pour les autres on
s'envisage pas d'y aller puis au final
cette opportunité est arrivé et puis on
a pu y aller mais oui en effet c'était
un peu dans le coin de la tête un peu un
rêve lointain les impôts qu'on d'y
retourner
l'édition suivante en fait pareil
c'était vraiment une opportunité on
était on a été accompagné par on est
accompagné par dassault systèmes qui
nous a offert cette opportunité d'y
retourner
donc on n'a pas dit non qu'est ce qu'on
y fait sur place concrètement pendant
trois jours que quel est le programme
que vous faites sur place
alors on est sur un stand on représente
notre dispositif fia pour être présent
sur le cms l'obligation de présenter
quelque chose de faire une démonstration
de quelque chose de notre produit de
développement donc
donc on est sur un site sur notre store
non présentes on arrête les gens les
gens viennent nous voir
l'idée c'est vraiment d'avoir anticipé
ce cms d'avoir contacté les personnes
d'avoir vu qu'ils pouvaient y aller
qu'ils allaient les contacts et faire un
peu les obliger enfin les tentes et à
venir sur notre stand pour leur
présenter le dispositif et donc on passe
nos journées là si on a la chance d'y
aller à plusieurs dans l'équipe on
tourne aussi pour aller voir ce que font
les autres et découvrir les nouvelles
technologies et vous y avez présenté
donc le giro liftant ces appareils que
vous développez votre start-up développe
vous l'avais pensé notamment dans un
laboratoire de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à vélizy votre
start up on le précise a été domicilié à
temps à montigny le bretonneux giraud
livre c'est en fait une nouvelle
solution de mobilité pour tous mobilité
notamment pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite elle est basée sur le gyropode
expliquez-nous le fonctionnement comment
ça fonctionne alors en fait ces bases et
voilà comme vous le dit très justement
s'est basé sur un gyropode donc les gens
connaissent ont gêné la marque c'est
ouais mais mais c'est une plateforme sur
deux roues qu'on contrôle avec son
centre de gravité en se penchant
légèrement en avant ou légèrement en
arrière pour avancer ou reculer
partant de cette technologie nous on a
développé un module robotique qui vient
ce plug & dessus permettre à tous types
d'usagé de se déplacer aussi bien assis
que debout sur le même principe donc
l'utilisateur qu'ils soient valides ou
en situation de handicap
contrôler son dispositif en se penchant
légèrement en avant ou légèrement en
arrière pour avancer ou reculer et à
tout moment peut décider la liberté de
pouvoir se verticaliser se retrouver
dans une position debout une position
intermédiaire et on a vu à l'image d'un
prototype un prototype 1 puisque le
projet a évolué si on revient juste sur
le début du projet l'idée comment elle a
été pensée c'est venu je crois dans
votre projet de recherche on précise que
vous êtes master en mai 4 vous avez un
master en mécatronique et vous êtes vous
avez également un doctorant robotics est
venu au cours de votre cursus cette idée
en fait c'est venu d'un de mes associés
co fondateur qui est président d'une
association loi 1901 sur les aides à la
mobilité et qui est venu présenter au
labo laboratoire d'ingénierie des
systèmes de versailles donc le bras
thouars de robotique de l'université de
versailles son idée de se dire est ce
qu'il serait possible de développer un
nouveau type de fauteuil roulant à
partir d'une technologie robotique et
l'université a dit banco c'est vraiment
une très bonne idée on pourrait mettre
un sujet de thèse de doctorat sujet
était de doctorat que j'ai obtenus et
donc j'ai fait mon doctorat robotique à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
sur le projet jirau lift à la suite de
quoi on se dit on peut pas s'arrêter une
nouvelle aventure comme ça et partir en
aventure entrepreneuriale et c'est pour
ça que que je suis parti en aventure
autres est ce que cette solution elle
est aujourd'hui unique au monde où il ya
des solutions similaires existent alors
il existe des solutions proches basé sur
des gyropodes qui permettent à des
personnes en situation de handicap de se
déplacer sur des gyropodes mais aucune
offre la possibilité de se verticaliser
on est les seuls à offrir à
l'utilisateur la possibilité de se
mettre debout et de su continuer à se
déplacer de boer avoir accès des objets
en hauteur des plans de travail etc
vous étiez au stade du prototype où en
est-on concrètement aujourd'hui
alors là on finalise l'industrialisation
on a lancé la sur le début d'année enfin
sur la fin d'année donc sur le début
d'année la production de la version
industrielle finale l'objectif est de
faire le marquage ce dispositif médical
de place par sur février mars et lancé
la commercialisation
juste après c'est l'objectif pour cette
année est ce que si du coup si vous
faites le bilan de votre participation à
ces deux crs est ce que vous y allez que
ça vous a aidé à grandir ça vous a aidé
dans votre projet oh oui oui énormément
énormément
ça nous a permis sur le recrutement
les gens de la ville donc énormément de
couverture presse après ça si il faut là
il faut la faire au bon moment ça c'est
quelque chose doit faire de manière
intelligente mais énormément de
recrutement qui ont eu lieu grâce à
associer ces gens qui m'ont déjà j'ai vu
que vous aviez fait le cs etc et qui ont
candidaté de cette manière là et et
beaucoup de retombées aussi en termes de
distribution des distributeurs médicaux
qui nous ont rencontrés sur le crs et
avec qui on a commencé à nouer contact
et et qui nous amènera peut-être qu'on a
un lancement commercial via ses
distributeurs alors aujourd'hui à start
up n'est plus domicilié à saint quentin
en yvelines vous êtes orléans vous avez
aussi des locaux à paris c'est ça
aujourd'hui
oui en effet on est on assure paris
l'équipe r&d et direction est sur la sur
la partie à orléans on a mis en place
l'unité d'assemblage l'unité de sav de
stockage et de production
l'appareil vous parliez tout à l'heure
des projets pour cette année donc là le
projet en tout cas en ligne de mire
c'est cet objectif commercialisation en
fait c'est notre objectif de nous est
entièrement tournée on entièrement
tourné là dessus et on a déjà un regard
sur le sur le giro ift deux puisqu'on
vient de lancer un programme de r&d sur
le délai développement du prochain giro
lift du coup on vous fait quoi pour 2020
20 des ventes
et puis et puis belles choses way sur
sur la commercialisation de beau
partenariat de co développement
est ce qu'on peut imaginer une nouvelle
participation au csss que c'est possible
en tout cas vous avez peut-être fait le
tour du sujet déjà non on ferme pas la
porte
c'est vrai que
ce qui est aussi compliqué pour nous
c'est que on est sur un dispositif qui
est assez médicale et que sur la période
de janvier il ya aussi des très gros
salon médicale dans le monde et donc il
va falloir peser les deux pour savoir
quel est le plus pertinent au moment du
stade de développement qu'on sera et
choisir ainsi bien merci à lambert va
être énorme et est repassé en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le see you de
jirau lift une start-up inquiet année on
le rappelle dans les yvelines
allez on va faire à présent à tours un
voyage dans le temps même dans le passé
toute cette semaine retour dans le
journal sur les événements qui ont
marqué 2010 9 dans les yvelines première
embarquement ce soir dans notre machine
à remonter le temps pour les mois de
janvier à mars 2010neuf l'année 2019 a
débuté par des naissances au 1er janvier
trois communes nouvelles ont vu le jour
dans les yvelines notamment le chesnais
rocancourt qui ne font qu'une désormais
les habitants sont appelés les chaînes
et courtois mais l'événement de cette
entame d'année c'est l'ouverture du
grand débat national réponses apportées
aux mouvements des gilet jaune commencé
deux mois plus tôt ce temps des changes
durera jusqu'à la mi mars plus de 190
réunions seront organisées dans les
yvelines dont l'une à trappes en
présence de la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn entre tout ce qui est fun
d'un gouvernement et la façon dont ça se
concrétise dans le quotidien des gens et
bien il ya un énorme écart
c'est peut-être la leçon qu'on va tirer
c'est que on doit se parler plus
fréquemment en direct les gilet jaune le
organiseront également une réunion de
leurs grands débats à elancourt le 22
février en présence de 450 personnes
venues de toute l'île de france
des gens en échange entre citoyens on y
retrouve tous bords politiques
donc on est
le concret pour moi on est dans le
concret voilà je pense qu'on va
ressortir plutôt intelligent qu'on était
entré je pense à un truc plus informés
en tout cas après qu'est-ce qu'elle sera
le la pac sur le reste de la population
c'est à nous de porter la bonne parole
après le premier trimestre 2010 9 vous
êtes également quelques nouveautés le
contrôleur rénové et inauguré entre la
verrière et mord pas un édifice doublé
pour fluidifier le trafic sur cet axe
routier stratégique à saint quentin en
yvelines
coût total de l'opération 9 millions
d'euros le pont il est efficace
puisqu'il n'y a plus de bouchons
d'entrée de ville donc c'est un vrai
confort pour l'ensemble des habitants
piétons
bello ont leur propre chemin
de cette manière on va favoriser aussi
j'espère un déplacement
120e dernières nouveautés dans
l'agglomération ou plutôt une
expérimentation le lancement de la
première entreprise éphémère en mars les
50 demandeurs d'emploi vont y travailler
pendant cette semaine avec l'objectif de
retourner vers une activité
professionnelle
ça glisse beaucoup je viens juste de
versailles là et à 10 alors ça va ça va
je suis presque arrivé
côté météo début 2019 était enneigée à
partir du 22 janvier le département
était placé à plusieurs reprises en
vigilance orange à la neige et des
opérations notamment de rétablissement
d'électricité ont été nécessaires au
plus fort de la crise sept mille deux
cents foyers yvelinois ont été privés de
courant
cette crise elle n'a rien eu de naturel
le 24 février dernier une fissure secret
dans le pipe line ile-de-france de total
conséquence un million de litres de
pétrole déversés dans des champs à
authouillet boissy sans avoir évité une
catastrophe écologique
il y aura bien sûr une enquête une
recherche en responsabilité et tout sera
à la charge du groupe total
tous les travaux de dépollution tous les
travaux d'intervention actuels et futurs
seront à la charge du groupe total de
même que l'indemnisation des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qu'il y subisse
ce préjudice de pollution au pétrole
en sport 2019 a commencé à vélo le
paris-nice première grande course
cycliste de l'année s'est élancé pour
cette édition de saint germain en laye
le lendemain la deuxième étape prenaient
le départ de la petite commune des
bréviaires dans le sud yvelines le
département assurée d'accueillir
jusqu'en 2023 la dernière étape de la
plus mythique des courses le tour de
france une convention a été signée en ce
sens le 20 mars entre l'organisateur de
la grande boucle et la collectivité le
même mois c'est une légende du cyclisme
français qui a fait le déplacement à
chatou raymond poulidor est venu à la
rencontre du public qui l'a tant chéri
l'une de ses dernières apparitions avant
sa mort le 13 novembre dernier ont
retracé évidemment un semblant parole
l'ensemble de ma carrière et la
conversation andréens souvent avec
jacques anquetil qui est toujours
présent ce fameux duel avec jacques
anquetil est toujours imposant question
comment se fait-il vous n'avez pas gagné
plusieurs tours de france disparition
également janvier 2019 de marcel azzola
91 ans l'un des grands accordéonistes
français habitants des yvelines le
marcel du chauffe marcel chauffe de
jacques brel dont le titre vesoul
et puis en mars dernier andré damien
ancien maire de versailles de 1977 à
ses obsèques ont rassemblé élus et
habitants en la cathédrale saint-louis
l'édifice religieux témoins quelques
mois avant d'un autre événement
l'ordination de bruno valentin nommé par
le pape françois évêque auxiliaire de
versailles enfin côté culture et
patrimoine on retiendra que le début
d'année 2010 9 a été celui du renouveau
celui du domaine de dampierre en
yvelines dont le parc a été rouvert au
public fin mars après de longues années
de fermeture et à l'orée de 2020 ce sont
les travaux du château du xviie siècle
qui vont démarrer fin du chantier est
espéré dans deux ans
[Musique]
retour dans le présent avec vous ou
michele lui d' eurobonds soir on
s'engagerait journalistes aux sports de
la rédaction de tv 60,18 vous nous
emmenez vous dans le futur un futur
proche projections sur les événements
sportifs à ne pas manquer en cette année
2009 1 dans le département et on
commence cette chronique avec du
cyclisme il y aura du cyclisme on l'a vu
dans la rétro le cyclisme anime encore
les yvelines sept jours en 2020 c'est
désormais une habitude la course
paris-nice s'élancera pour la onzième
année consécutive depuis les yvelines
d'après nos informations les coureurs
partiront le dimanche 8 mars prochain
depuis plaisir pour traverser une partie
du département lendemain l étape partira
depuis chevreuse pour rejoindre le
loiret on écoute jean michel richefort
le vice président de la fédération
française de cyclisme paris nice et la
course au soleil
c'est la première grande course
internationale de la saison avec ti fria
tiko et bien sûr la belle et les
meilleurs mondiaux seront au rendez vous
et c'est important d'avoir les plus
grandes
les les plus grands coureurs mondiaux au
départ bien sur paris nice c'est une
très très grande course internationale
on parle aussi dans la rétrospective le
tour de france passera également dans
les yvelines pour la deuxième année
consécutive
ce sera le 19 juillet prochain le
peloton s'élancera depuis mantes la
jolie pour une dernière étape de 122
kilomètres en direction des champs
elysées et ce sera un événement à ne pas
manquer
c'est une formidable fête populaire
pendant trois semaines et une dernière
étape qui va traverser une grande partie
des yvelines à partir de menthe
là c'est vraiment quelque chose de grand
événement de course à pied l'une des
plus importantes ce sera le paris à
versailles pour cette 43e édition 25
mille coureurs s'élanceront le 27
septembre prochain depuis la capitale
pour un 16 2 km avant cette date les
yvelines vont accueillir l'eco trail de
paris le 14 mars prochain le des plus
longues courses de france plusieurs
centaines de participants vont s'élancer
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines pour un trail de 80 km qui
les emmènera jusqu'à la tour eiffel par
me fabien parmentier de montigny le
bretonneux
il participera à sa 13ème édition les
principales difficultés on va dire c'est
que c'est très roulant donc il est
réputé comme être comme comme étant une
course très roulante c'est à dire sur
laquelle il ya peu de temps de repos on
court beaucoup n'y a pas forcément
beaucoup de dénivelé il ya 1500 mètres
de dénivelé et donc à partir de là faut
sans cesse être dans la relance et avoir
une bonne une bonne gestion de course à
quelques mètres de l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
accueillir pour la première fois de son
histoire un match de volley ball
la rencontre sera organisée le 28 mars
prochain et devrait opposer les équipes
de première division
saint quentin en yvelines devrait
également accueillir comme tous les ans
depuis 2002 l'open de france de golf le
rendez-vous retrouvera la saison
estivale du 2 au 5 juillet est ce que
vous aimez vous dépassez les gorilles se
marier je crois que les montrer dans des
reportages sur tv 78 si vous aimez la
boue la boue pourquoi pas alors ce
rendez vous devrait à vous intéresser
pour les plus courageux le mud et paris
sera organisé les 13 et 14 juin à berne
au programme 1 7 et 1 13 km et surtout
bout
ou de google gorille pour les milliers
de participants merci michael les
téléspectateurs vous retrouve dans un
instant votre émission le cetud sport
premier numéro de cette année 2020 merci
beaucoup pour cette chronique en
football la désillusion pour les joueurs
de versailles l'épopée en coupe de
france c'est terminé au stade des 32e de
finale samedi le fcv s'est incliné 2
buts à 1 face à granville au stade mont
boron pas de clubs plus de club
yvelinois est désormais dans la
compétition ambiance dans les tribunes
avec vous michael et demi d'euros un
stade bien garni pour une affiche
historique 2000 supporteurs ont fait le
déplacement pour voir ce 32e de finale
de coupe de france entre versailles et
granville les versets qui évolue en
nationale 3 n'avait plus atteint ce
stade de la compétition depuis 2011
aujourd'hui j'espère qu'il va marquer
malgré leurs divisions d'écart les
versets qui marque en premier sur
penalty mais se font rejoindre quelques
minutes plus tard le score à la mi temps
un partout
je pense que techniquement les deux
équipes se valent mais ça va jouer très
serré je pense granville marque aura un
second but en seconde période malgré
quelques actions en fin de match et les
encouragements de leurs supporters
versailles ne reviendra pas et se fait
sortir de la coupe de france sur le
score de 2 1 ils ont entre un petit peu
plus d'expérience que nous là sur ce mot
sur ce genre de match qui sont quand
même important donc j'ai tiré un petit
plus d'expérience après je pense pas
qu'on avait quelque chose à leur envier
qu'il soit techniquement ou physiquement
une ou deux erreurs défensives mans qui
nous ont coûté des buts on était puni
froidement mais voilà c'est la vérité du
32e de finale de coupe de france de ce
niveau là et là dessus il faut il faut
apprendre
du côté des supporters les sentiments
sont partagés on est quand même content
de la prestation des joueurs mais on
aurait pu gagner faire beaucoup mieux
mais c'est pas grave on a vécu quand
même un bon match quand on regarde le
contenu
ça laisse ça laisse des regrets par cas
c'est dommage voilà maintenant il ya des
faits de jeu et perdre et vont continuer
à considérer championnat de n3 ce sera
la consommation des stars et les versets
y sont à l'heure actuelle premiers du
championnat de nationale 3 avec un point
d'avancé sur leur dauphin ivry pour se
remettre de cette défaite en coupe il
faudra l'emporter ce samedi 11 janvier à
domicile contre l'équipe 2 du paris
saint germain
il va s'en vendre tout le mois de
janvier les galettes des rois sont les
produits prisés du moment aux
boulangeries notamment ce week end
épiphanie à l'angélique à montigny le
bretonneux les fourneaux sorte de la
frangipane depuis déjà quinze jours ce
sont les 1500 à 3000 galette qui vont
être produites
la galette à la crème d'amande reste la
préférée des clients qui sont venus la
chercher a dès le lendemain de noël et
dans cette boulangerie on organise des
opérations spéciales tout en générosité
les propos sont recueillis par marylène
yapi chinois nous avons 20 fev gagnante
chaque fèves trouvait en fait
ou la porte ils ont gardé de six
personnes en échange et on présente deux
fois par semaine plus pour les
entreprises des galettes jusqu'à un
mètre de diamètre
donc on fait 70 personnes sur la galette
et cela a été tranchée en décembre la
meilleure galette aux amandes des
yvelines catégorie salariés etc les
siennes lionel barbé à droite sur la
photo boulanger chez un barca délice aux
clayes-sous-bois a remporté cette
distinction attribuée par la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat des yvelines
sixième édition pour ce concours qui
juge les pâtissiers sur deux galettes
évalue les évalue sur leur cuisson leur
aspect ou leur taille voilà c'est la fin
de cette édition du 7 8 journal une
nouvelle édition retrouvez dès demain
sur tv 60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]
oh